if you are a guidance counselor in a
college or a high school and you look at
someone and you recommend that they
spend 150,000 dollars and go 150
thousand dollars in debt in order to get
a job making twenty five thousand you
should be sued for malpractice
your guidance is so far off of reality
you should be fired from your job now I
don't know if a guidance counselor told
that lady and last call to do that or
not
Oh any idea but this idea that the
quote/unquote adults in our culture your
parents your teachers your school
administrators and new guidance
counselors don't look at someone who's
18 or 19 years old in the face and say
hey stupid
don't spend $250,000 getting a degree to
make 25 grand that's a bad idea if
you're not willing to say that somebody
ought to smack you you really owe the
young people in your life some guidance
see we do not have a student loan crisis
in America we have a parenting crisis
moms and dads your 18 year old may look
like they're all grown up their bodies
may be adult looking bodies their brains
are not fully developed and I remember
when I was 18 and you remember when you
were 18 sometimes you need someone to
love you enough to go a stupid don't
spend $200,000 getting agree make 25
grand this is a dumb idea getting a
degree in you know German polka history
is a bad plan it's a bad plan there's no
jobs for it the only jobs for becoming a
professor of German polka history it's
the only possible job for that left
handed puppetry there is not a long
large call for this and yo I got a
degree I gave on the job because you got
ass too
goodbye degree you studied something
that nobody wants to hire you to do
that's why and and nobody loves you no
the adults in your life loved you enough
or had the backbone enough to look at
you and go you're stupid that's crazy
you guys so moms and dads you need to
love these young people you got a 16
year old I know they act like they've
got all together I know they think they
got it all together every one of us
listening to this discussion right now
know they don't have it together they're
the only ones on the planet that think
they have it together
and if you think they do you're that
you're the second person but the rest of
us don't we know that 16 and 17 year
olds need guidance and so we're going to
select a school that this family can
afford without you going deeply in debt
to go get a college degree because
college degrees are not a guarantee of
success let me say it again college
degrees are wonderful I believe in
education walking around without
knowledge is a bad idea get a degree go
study academics are important but they
do not cause you to be successful we all
know highly-educated broke people when
you meet successful people is the first
thing that comes out of your mouth go oh
it's because of where they went to
school it's because they got a degree no
that's not what I hear when I meet
people that are successful what I find
are character traits inside of them that
cause them to become successful grit
passion perseverance integrity these are
the things that cause people to be
successful college degrees are a tool in
your belt the knowledge is a tool in
your belt to help you be successful but
quit telling people the lie that college
degrees are necessary for success or a
direct indicator of success they are not
especially stupid but degrees it's it's
the paradox of this generation it's the
the oxymoron of this generation that we
are stupid about education think about
that sentence this culture is stupid
about education is that not on oxymoron
isn't on a paradox
it's amazing now do I think education is
important yes I do
but just random but going to college
just because I like the trees on the
campus and somebody told me I needed a
college degree the campus is pretty oh
shut up I have never hired a single
individual and I've hired over a
thousand 1,500 people in my life never
hired anybody because of the trees on
their campus not once
very seldom do I actually hire them
because of the degree other than because
of how they interviewed how they carried
themselves whether they had poise
whether that knowledge whether they had
emotional intelligence the ability to
interact and play well with others and
whether they had the skillset to
actually do the jlb that's in front of
us to do the job the thing that needs
doing do you know how to do that think
people think moms and dads step up be a
little stronger don't be such wishes
tell them what it is grandma's grandpa's
look over at that kid go don't do that
honey that's a dumb idea don't do that
it's going to leave a mark it's a dumb
idea don't go then go $250,000 in debt
so you can say you went to that school
that's stupid stupid somebody's got to
tell somebody this this is why we have a
student loan crisis it's not because yes
education is expensive but education is
not so unaffordable that it cannot be
attained without deeply going into debt
the problem is people going into debt
that aren't thinking and so they're
going to places they can't afford it's
like there are other parts of their
lives and they're studying things that
don't have any marketable value and I'm
not picking on that poor lady to just
call bless her heart she's in a mess I'm
sorry she's there and I hope she can
work her way out of it but it's just sad
they're looking at a $3,000 truck to
solve a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar problem it just breaks my heart
and and I just want
back about five years or six years in
this conversation and go you're getting
a master's degree why and what and it's
going to pay you what and the guidance
counselor just nods with their eyes
crossed because they're mailing it in
and giving no guidance the definition of
guidance counselor is you ought to give
some guidance and some counsel hello
it's in your title instead of just going
oh yeah everybody needs to get everybody
ought to go work for the school and you
know you ought to go deeply in debt no
stop it stop it grownups and this
culture are going to start being
grownups and telling the little ones
what's stupid looks like so they don't
have to repeat themselves it'll kill you
it's just it's killing us now the good
news is you can get out of this mess if
you're one of them and you're in this
mess you just got to go make some money
and pay the bill and we talk to people
every day was the young man just a
minute ago paid off a hundred and twenty
nine thousand dollars in debt to his
parents which was effectively student
loan debt it was not technically student
loan debt but he's borrowed for him to
go to school he just turned right around
and cleaned it up so it can be done you
can clean it up and he's working his
butt off and you know has a good field
of study if I recall it was engineer if
I remember right and taking all the
overtime we can get up to 90 K right
and so at 27 years old say you know that
you know you you can you can get out of
that but I don't even want you in that I
want you to choose better so moms and
dads two things guidance counselors two
things number one college choice where
you go to school needs to be someplace
you can afford to pay for the second
thing study something that actually has
use in the marketplace you cannot afford
to spend a hundred thousand dollars to
get a degree that does not cause you to
earn money
unless you just got extra hundred grand
laying around if your family's got an
extra hundred grand laying around and
you just want to broaden your horizons
by studying German polka history that's
fine go ahead and do it but don't blame
the educational system on the fact you
can't get a job and don't blame the
culture that has let you down sorry
sweetie
buckle up buttercup we have to be
realistic about how we do this stuff
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]